[Музика]
вітаю всіх, мене звуть о, давай, Ма,
і давайте проведемо урок англійської.
маєте спільне з їжею, особливо
з гамбургерами, ви сьогодні дізнаєтесь, що
гамбургери та есе мають багато спільного
, подивіться на це правильно, чи хотіли б ви
з'їсти це ні, це виглядає нудно,
це виглядає несмачно, йому, очевидно, не вистачає
чогось ось чого  Я думаю, як
викладач, коли я читаю деякі зі своїх студентських
есе, хм, чому б нам не поглянути на
це, воно виглядає великим, схоже, що в ньому
є трохи, у нього є зелень, у
нього є овочі, я бачу шматочок
м’яса або  але це виглядає не так заманливо,
як цікаво читати, якби це було есе, я
б сказав, що добре, а тепер давайте подивимося
на бургер, який, на мою думку,
тут найкращий, я б сказав, що це
правильний розмір і правильна форма, яку я можу  подивіться
всі інгредієнти, це виглядає смачно,
якби це було те есе, яке я б зробив  кажу, що це
есе варте прочитання, я сподіваюся, що в ньому є
всі інгредієнти, будь-хто
скаже, що потрібно подивитись на малюнок і
побачити, як мої гамбургери пов’язані з
правильним есе, насправді з його структурою,
саме сьогодні ми збираємося
написати твір
це  типове завдання, яке ви маєте на будь-якому
іспиті чи тесті, міжнародному
чи місцевому, і в будь-якому випадку написання есе – це
універсальна навичка, про яку ви повинні
знати і добре вправлятися, давайте
подивимося на мій бургер і на картинку
, яку сьогодні буде писати есе
есе про переваги/недоліки, яке є дуже поширеним, вам можна
дати будь-які теми, як-от технології та
освіта, це може бути медицина, це може бути
засоби масової інформації, це може бути все, що
наше сьогодні, люди тепер мають
свободу вчитися жити та працювати в будь-якій
точці світу завдяки  розвиток
комунікаційних технологій та
транспорту чи переваги цього
розвитку переважують над недоліками,
правильно це переваги недоліки
есе, коли я прочитав тему, я піклуюся  ully
план у мене в руках, і обидва на папері
ідеї, які я маю свої ідеї щодо цієї теми,
є наступними,
є недоліки, і я
назву їх пізніше, але є більше
переваг, що є моєю особистою думкою,
тому структура нашого есе
буде такою  наступне будь-який твір, коли ми
починали, ми маємо вступ, і, як
ви знаєте, ми подивимося пізніше, але
це буде верхня булочка нашого есе або
наш гамбургер, тому
це буде вступ,
правильний, гарний і міцний саме той
сформуй потрібну кількість речень
і слів правильно, що у тебе далі, якщо
я збираюся говорити про переваги,
які, на мою думку, переважають у
цій темі, я б залишив їх на
останніх двох абзацах, а мій перший основний
абзац називатиму  недолік
, скажімо, що це мій перший шматочок м'яса.
Я представляю вам думку про недоліки
прямо далі, я
б використав ідеї, які
будуть чудовою булочкою в середині та іншою
скибка м’яса будь-який есе повинен мати
висновок, у моєму випадку це булочка
внизу мого есе, тому подивіться на
малюнок і давайте подивимося на
структуру нашого есе або гамбургер, як
ми його називаємо сьогодні, щоб воно було  бути
організацією основного абзацу
вступом верхньої булочки тут ми розповідаємо
основну ідею, абзац перший, у моєму випадку
це недоліки бургер - це
переваги, параграф третій, ще
переваги та висновок, який
зазвичай містить короткий зміст, правильний,
давайте подивимося  у нашій темі та почніть
писати наше есе, люди тепер мають
свободу вчитися жити та працювати в будь-якій
точці світу завдяки розвитку
комунікаційних технологій та
транспорту, переваги цієї
розробки переважили недоліки
правильно, давайте почнемо зі вступу
Введення, де ви зазвичай
перефразуйте їх основну ідею або завдання,
будь ласка, використовуйте синоніми, уникайте
слів, які ви надаєте в самому завданні,
правильно, моє вступне слово буде б  У
наступні дні багато людей вибирають
жити та працювати в інших країнах,
що стало можливим
завдяки зручності авіаперельотів та сучасних
комунікацій, я схильний вірити, що
це має більше переваг, ніж недоліків,
зверніть увагу на підкреслені слова
, це  синоніми, тому люди мають
свободу
я кажу, що люди вибирають розвиток
транспорту. Я використовую зручність
авіаперельотів, переваги та недоліки в
моєму випадку я використовую слова як переваги та
недоліки, що є дуже гарним і надійним
вступом, давайте рухаємося праворуч, перейдемо до
параграфа 1  оскільки ми домовилися, у моєму резюме
буде сказано, що я не для людей, які переїжджають,
щоб залишити навчання та працювати в різних
країнах, тому є кілька
недоліків, і я збираюся
їх назвати зараз, недоліком
цього розвитку є відстань  що
поміщається між членами сім’ї, якщо людина
переїжджає, правда, що авіаперельоти
та такі пристрої, як Skype, означають, що
спілкування та контакт можуть бути
стверджується, однак, імовірно, що
людина зможе повертатися додому лише
один-два рази на рік під час канікул,
і розмова по скайпу або електронною поштою – це
не те саме, що контакт віч-на-віч,
давайте повернемося до нашого есе або
Бергера  у нас є проміжний період, який я
ввів недоліки, тепер я перехожу
до переваг, пам'ятайте, що
це мої основні моменти, тому ми дійсно
повинні бути обережними, вводячи тут
основні ідеї та допоміжні пропозиції,
незважаючи на це, по-перше,
це може принести значні переваги в
житті людей  це означає, що люди
мають можливість побачити інші
частини світу та спосіб життя людей,
наприклад, люди із Заходу часто їдуть на
роботу в Азію чи Близький Схід, і
навпаки,
це охоплює життя багатьох людей, коли
вони дізнаються про  інші мови
звичаї культури та різні способи
роботи з власної країни, тепер
ми підходимо до третього абзацу, який
буде соковитим шматком, який дійсно має
показати право на його опі  ми тверда
думка про переваги цих сучасних
розробок, давайте подивимося, що я
маю тут, на додаток до цього на більш широкому
рівні, це також може принести користь іншим
країнам, якщо хтось переїжджає на
роботу, зазвичай тому,
що для ілюстрації медсестер потрібна їхня вміння
і лікарі часто переїжджають працювати в
лікарні в інші країни, коли їх
не вистачає, тому це дуже цінно
для місця, куди вони переїхали зараз, так як можна
закінчити без висновку, пам’ятайте, що
висновок є підсумком усіх ваших ідей
і, нарешті, висловлення вашої думки,
давайте  подивіться, що я маю тут, тому я б
стверджував, що, хоча
нинішня тенденція
навчатися і працювати за кордоном має недоліки, вони
переважають переваги, які воно може
збагатити життя людей і життя
людей у країнах, куди вони пе
еїхали добре  о, давайте подивимося на наш
слайд,
а тепер у нашому Бургері є
все, що ми обговорювали з вами
з самого початку, він має вступ
у верхній частині він має правильний висновок
і має три абзаци, тому в
загальній складності у мене є п’ять абзаців есе,
вступний параграф перший із зазначенням
недоліків, параграф другий пропонує
перший набір переваг для підтримки моїх
ідей.
висновок, що містить
короткий зміст усіх ідей і висловлює
думку письменника, як ви, очевидно,
бачите, що не лише п'ять абзаців
відіграють величезну роль у цьому гамбургері чи есе,
є й інші аспекти, які роблять його
дійсно соковитим і смачним, я б сказав,
що соковитий словниковий запас  у нашому випадку
це синоніми та сполучні слова,
давайте подивимося на деякі
приклади синонімів, які використовуються під час написання
мого есе.
можна
назвати переваги та недоліки або плюси
та мінуси, це ви знаєте, чи маєте
можливість добре зараз у нас є погані
st  розірваний есе, насправді, у нього є
деякі інгредієнти, якщо ви подивитеся на наші
параграфи так,
все введення, у ньому є два параграфи,
які можуть бути одним із зазначених переваг,
один із зазначенням недоліків
та висновком, однак, оскільки ми
вирішили, що це виглядає не дуже смачно,
це не так  не виглядаю спокусливо, і якщо я подивлюся
на цей нудний твір, то
я б не вітав його,
однак секретні інгредієнти, про які
ми з вами говорили, можуть бути
якоюсь гарною граматикою, соковитим
словником, синонімами та сполучними
словами  далі ви знайдете слайд
із різноманітними словами-посиланнями, які ми сказали,
які я пропоную вам зберегти, скопіювати та
використовувати. Використовуйте свої
нотатки, коли ви практикуєте писати есе,
звертайтеся до списків слів-посилань, які
ви надаєте під час написання наступного
есе добре давайте подивимося, що ми можемо
зробити з нашим не дуже привабливим
гамбургером,
але все ж таки зв'язні слова були використані, тому
давайте зробимо я  та смачний бекон. Я поставлю це
на вершину моєї основної ідеї,
представляючи мій абзац 1.
Недоліки в нашому випадку, куди ми йти
далі,
ми могли б додати красивий синонім або
інше зв’язне слово, що вводить
параграф 2, тож між параграфами 1 і
2 чому?  t у нас є якісь овочі або
в нашому випадку це буде інший
вантаж або красивий синонім або зв'язне
слово правильно, ми додаємо трохи сиру на
помідор так, давайте, ви
завжди можете подивитися на так, використовуючи більше
овочів правильно, і будь-який вчитель би
Я вдячний за те, що ви переходите від однієї точки до
іншої точки, що нагадує про ці
наслідки, перш за все, слідуючи
наступному в моєму випадку, це був би
прекрасний салат, який я додаю до свого бургера
, вирішувати вам, куди ви його
правильно представити, давайте подивимося на посилання
слова, які використані в моєму есе, дивлюся на
цей крем, тим не менш, я схильний
вірити, що D має більше переваг, ніж
недоліків, але цілком ймовірно, що
людина зможе повернутися додому лише
один або два  o раз на рік, незважаючи на це
, є значні переваги, які він може
принести людям, по-перше, це означає,
що люди мають можливість побачити
інші частини світу, наприклад,
люди із Заходу часто їдуть на роботу в
Азію чи Близький Схід, і навпаки
в  На додаток до цього на більш широкому рівні,
іншим країнам може бути корисно
ілюструвати медсестер і лікарів, які часто
хочуть працювати в лікарнях, тому я б
стверджував, що, хоча
нинішня тенденція до вивчення має недоліки,
яка буде продовжена, давайте
повернемося до самого  початок того, що
ви робите після того, як ви побачите план теми, якщо
його перевага, недолік,
ви вирішите, за чи
проти, якщо це есе з п’яти параграфів,
якщо у вас достатньо роботи, щоб зробити його
п’ятьма абзацами,
будь ласка, скажіть, що ви
не погоджуйтеся з першим, а потім у
параграфах другому та третьому з тими, які ви
, нарешті, у своєму висновку у своєму
резюме скажете як ваші особисті ідеї та
цінності  Ви можете залишити свій час на
коректуру, щоб перевірити, чи
правильно влаштовані ваші абзаци, чи
правильна ваша граматика, чи є у вас
синоніми, щоб уникати повторів і
чи достатньо сполучних слів, що сполучають
слова або перехідних слів, як вони
називаються. У мене є деякі,
які завжди будуть  допоможіть мені
нагадати, чи є у мене джерело в моєму есе,
щоб джерело було в моєму гамбургері, який
соус буде добре, все
вищезгадане, правильно, ви можете вибрати, як додати
додаткове слово або синонім або
слово-посилання, щоб зробити його соковитим  і чудово,
тепер на екрані ви знову бачите різні
типи слів-посилань. Я пропоную вам
скопіювати їх і посилатися на них, коли ви
працюєте над своїми наступними есе
[Музика]
[  Музика],
а тепер давайте подивимося на весь твір з
усіма п'ятьма абзацами, будь ласка, зверніть
увагу на слова-посилання, які я
використав, зверніть увагу на
використані синоніми та на його структуру
[Музика]
[  Музика]
і те, що я буду робити зараз, я
збираюся насолоджуватися своїм гамбургером, дуже дякую
за урок, і я побачимось  наступного
разу
[Музика]
ви